what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to do a first
time watching for a a really high brow
comedy supposedly
grown-ups today joined by my friend all
the way in the big apple salad Amanda
Sally Lamonica
full of salad Sally how are you today
I'm a I'm a full salad today had some
dinner
stressing on the side I don't know where
it is
I don't know what's going on yeah a
little tossed today anyway
um if you guys leave a like that's the
first sort of business please go ahead
and do that secondly Sally you and Adam
Sandler fan I like Adam Sandler more
than a lot of people seem to like yeah
man I love Adam Sandler so much can I
fun facts yes fun fact and I'm zooming
in on the video I have like one of those
uh movie canvases where they take a
screenshot of each frame a color
attached to it and it creates this cool
work of art okay and the one behind me
is actually from The Wedding Singer oh
no way and my brother got it for me
because it's my favorite rom-com so oh I
love that stand there following Sally on
her own YouTube channel she's producing
a bunch of crap lately and stop crap but
she's producing stuff yeah What The Hell
she's just producing stuff I should have
left it at that also uh full interaction
watch long as we stick it with your own
copy available for our super sexy
rejects over our patreon page thank you
to all who have joined your support
means the world all right Sally you
ready to do this
I am so ready I love him let's uh let's
finally watch this
this is really straightforward title
credits okay yep
Adam Sandler playing basketball
shoes
oh David Spade
young dudes he's a ladies man
oh my God
that is good that's a great lookalike
that's great casting yeah
oh my God no
no
[Music]
nicely done cast of stranger things
I want you to play Life just like you
played that game today
so when that final buzzer of life goes
off you'll have no regrets
here's to coach
[Music]
this is a really fancy party for a kid's
basketball game I was gonna say damn I
graduated college I didn't even get a
dinner I do like outside on up here like
that no
stop texting the nanny you know how
gross that is for a kid to Texas Nanny
this isn't good tiger what are you
trying to poison me good Lord go back to
texting I I don't I ever want to hear
that out loud again
what is going on here
uh wow
someone drunk oh child
man he said your friend coach buzzer
went to heaven I was trying to find
heaven for you on the Navy station so
you could go visit him that thought
process
I know
okay grown up of her
con your mom damn
look at Kevin James just locking it down
that would have been so fun to film oh
my God I made the pumpkin risotto that
we saw in Rachel Ray's seasons of Summer
special it's awful Mom it tastes like
roadkill Dan do you see how they talk to
me do you hear that
now you know your father works very hard
at keeping this house clean and putting
three meals on the table for us every
day hello I brought us a pizza
what a [ __ ] move oh my God
Happy Pizza you broke my heart
looks like it's his time of the month
that's not a man
see that ass is still growing got a
little Kardashian in there
it's my mother hello Mama and Sonia I'm
so pleased to meet you I'm little
Lenny's wife oh what a spicy quesadilla
you got yourself
what oh didn't I tell you to turn the
phone off there Greg yeah but it's my
massage therapist what no no no cell
phones wait no cell phones and I'm out
of here
who's ready to get their funeral on
oh my God hey so these are your kids
and who's that girl that's not a nanny
is it oh no this is a a friend of ours
from China oh yeah no I've been on that
website
[Laughter]
hey nice ears you get the NFL package on
those these guys are all mean
I know it's like I haven't seen you in a
while and our coach is dead let's just
insult each other for like five minutes
it's Captain caring of the SS melodrama
oh he's gonna play this one big thank
you hey hey hey
kind of crazy seeing all these people in
one movie mm-hmm I don't make jokes at
funerals because it's disrespectful but
if that's part of your healing process
I'm cool with it Ah that's nice hey are
you cool with the finger in you
oh my God and this must be your mother
my wife Your Design Line is so beautiful
thank you thank you and I love your
scarves thank you she'll be tying me up
at those later oh ho ho ho that's she's
gonna pull a little hamstring
no no oh
that was a long time
so you cannot pay me enough
that sounded like a real laugh like Adam
Sandler was not acting last year
I understand that the Saint Mark's team
of 1978 was the only championship team
the the coach ever had Believe It or Not
Robbie and Marcus were actually shorter
back in 1970.
five bucks it takes them down on one
knee
you're wrong
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh man oh
Domino's
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
he just had five dollars I was gonna say
who just has five dollars
Mommy I want some milk oh sure Angel
come here give me a little something
what
Jesus oh he's uh 48 months that's four
we meant to stop last year but um he
likes it so much and we don't like to
say no this is so messed up
pork please
no no no
looks like she didn't get the memo
there's so many fat jokes in this movie
but not fly now
[Laughter]
Maria Bello though she is hot I like
what Adam Sandler produces movies for
him and his friends to hang out
yeah I want to do that he's got a dream
job it'll do for one night yeah you can
handle it
daddy where's that machine
I was getting rid of the Moss honey
where's it taking them hell don't say
that again I'm trying to help Mexico
Mexico
they're all all right I promise you see
look at this guy
yeah he's still sleeping it's dead dad
oh a part swing I know what
bunions you know I actually have a
poultice I make using Maize just say
corn maze is corn everybody my name is
it's fantastic it's amazing
[Laughter]
my Afflicted area is print oh my God oh
my God deny is it how in the world is
anybody supposed to get some sleep
knowing they under the same Rufus Toby
Brian over here
I know Jesus
and we used to shoot bottle rockets at
each other you always go for the guy's
face because you want to Blind them okay
that's a little much bro no no I know
kids don't do that
[Laughter]
a tree baby you know what that means we
get to hang ourselves oh my gosh and
that doesn't make you want to go nuts it
makes me like I I I I you know
let me show you yeah oh it was a
terrible idea yeah yeah you're right you
got to back it up back it up this is why
women live longer you can't just assume
the Rope is why would they make him go
first
[Applause]
Oh I thought he was gonna hit the
boulders
I gotcha
very good
oh no remember we used to come here in
high school last night
what's wasted
a nice one eggy uh wasted uh kids is
something that happens when you have a
hankering for ice cream well I want to
get wasted I want to get totally wasted
I want to get wasted every single day of
my life
[Laughter]
getting it we can drink all we want I'll
shut it off I'm gonna have a Coke and I
know Donna she's gonna want a spray
correct sweetie and uh
yeah imagine that little kid growing up
and watching this movie being like what
did I do just get the water we're done
talking about water tap water uh I go
get the boss baby
that last shot
your foot was on the line shouldn't have
counted they don't look like they could
make it up and down the court anymore
what about you you put on a few pounds
from when I was 12 yes
hmm
rematch I did
next time you come to town I'll have
plenty of that Boss Water for your kid
Voss water by the way with a V it's
it's what is Voss water can we afford it
you don't know what Voss water is no no
more sophisticated than me
Greg it's water in a glass bottle duh we
gotta go to Milan it's pretty cool the
Roxanne's got her fall line coming out
fashion week and they show boobies on
Italian TV
I'm going to Italy I mean no no we all
we I didn't tell you guys we're probably
gonna go to Italy
Gloria and I are making breakfast for
everybody using a dehydrator well I'd
rather be hit by dehydrated fruit than a
processed
so you think you're rich and you can
just slap people dehydrated I don't
think that don't say that
[Laughter]
would you like me to make an egg white
frittata Mr fader I mean is is that what
you're doing in science class
that's so stupid just let her in on it
right just tell her
cooking the bacon not in here that's
dead animal flesh and it's not going
near the vegan food murderer what do I
do with it oh I know oh I'm sorry buddy
I'm sorry
yes what
ew oh no oh dude
clean this thing right yeah I cleaned
this thing oh man thanks a lot by the
way uh McIntyre Island ain't close damn
that [ __ ] cooked fast
stop oh stop ew this movie's literally
just them hanging out huh
and they got paid Millions
he won at life honestly mad respect
this is like the white people Friday I
love it black guy no I had a bad blood
sugar test at my last check up and Sally
cut me off oh I got my own hidden stash
I'm not stupid I hide them under my
clothes the smell on my sweat socks mask
of the chocolate smell and and the looks
of your underwear Master chocolate
stains
laughs
are you peeing or as a diesel truck
turning off what the hell is that
well listen to hamper Morse code I think
he's sending a message in Morse code
the good news is these girls are gonna
say hi to it no
no they don't all look like that ladies
I think 300 pounds ow
[Laughter]
goodbye to you
friend wise advice giver
buzzer noise maker
oh come on it really messed up my
marriages
it's my fault man
I'm already making it about this they're
going to be here in about 20 minutes
wait what
I can use a piece of chicken I don't
know
piece of crap car what is going on this
movie just looks a lot better
shut up how do you get that from that
95 of that's got to be from the mother
and I am lowballing hey Jasmine how is
that possible
my old man lent me this turd your old
man yeah my boyfriend 47 years old you
know I wish I let guys my own age but
I'm just chasing the dad that ran out on
me
what
[Laughter]
okay Mom
I don't know but it feels right
I hope that car never gets fixed
I don't think it will
took the spark plugs out nice
oh my God
three of them have like the hottest
wives too like what are you doing
and shift
shift
this is so messed up
oh honey
you blown your gasket
[Music]
[Laughter]
what at least he's getting something
I've been shut out ever since DM found
out she was pregnant oh yeah that'll
happen can you have sex when they're
pregnant or does that hurt the baby no
Mackenzie can because the baby thinks
he's getting a Tootsie Roll
I can't believe we're doing this how do
we always listening
wait what are they doing like Arrow
roulette so they're just gonna shoot it
up and see like where it lands oh this
is the stupidest idea in the world yeah
why
women live longer
[Applause]
ride with the dog be
dog beer that's awful
[Music]
ouch that looked real
no what are you doing
[Laughter]
oh
how did he fall over if it was like in
the ground oh well I've got attacked by
an India but then yeah he got away what
an attack by an Indian Daddy what
happened Amber
[Laughter]
yes I'm down here Daddy's hurt you got
another one yeah hey
hey
so mean
that's Maggie Chung she's a great
actress all we need is a pull ties with
some maze shut up are you insane get
some alcohol on this [ __ ] you should
know plenty about that you were bored
during the prohibition there's the snap
that was bigger than I thought it was
gonna be that was mean
hi this is Roxanne fader I just want to
make sure
okay now your tooth yeah that's great
honey just put it under the pillow and
I'll put a dollar in there later okay
listen what Becky I'm on the phone I'll
put the dollar under oh
there's no tooth fairy what is going on
in this room
no matter what's happening
it's a tooth fairy Greg did you ever
believe in the tooth fairy
it's a real life moment Greg she's
learning that they have they've lost
it's really important family he made a
mistake parents make mistakes remember
the time I told Greg that babies come
from Mommy's poop did you believe that
Greg
they don't
didn't they say no cell phones they're
not on their cell phones
I'm dead
I'm on a SpongeBob
that's cool I never did that
no no I tried it it didn't work that
well for me I was like oh this sucks yes
I have always been the Tooth Fairy Becky
so so so much okay
okay come on you're costing me a fortune
the bird is okay
[Music]
Bean we have to learn how to share even
with birds
yeah
what hold it like this
down low and throw it and let the rock
do the magic
your feet
nice
oh that's great do you know how to skip
rocks Mrs fader are you kidding me I am
the best at this
give me that wait
[Laughter]
I forgot how to skip a rock
now I think it's gonna take a couple of
days to figure it out
I think we better stay
are you kidding me
to learn to skip a rock no maybe she's
not as smart as we thought yeah see
you couldn't get that in Milan
oh my God
hot understanding
it's rare
got them at a store called Naughty and
Nice Marcus said it was the only one
that was open
the only place open for bathing suits in
the summer
hi bathing suit at Stop and Shop
s
that is very peace
where did she get it
hey somebody likes what you see
what they have been [ __ ] no I'm just
kidding I'm kidding he's got weird face
is that an eight pack
put mine to work
Sally
wow that's it girl
does he like Sally don't fall for that
crap you stay away from him what are you
talking about he's gay isn't he no he
just seems gay he's a genius
he's a genius yes
I could say nevermind
there you go who's that let's go
[Music]
is it coming this way he's coming this
way he's coming towards us please go for
the granny
yeah it's Gotta there's gotta be a catch
[Music]
hey what's up ladies
you american ladies you put out the
Saskatchewan eh laughs
[Applause]
that's so mean everything was on
steroids except for his voice
I feel like that would take longer than
just waiting in life
wow this does look fun and they got to
like get paid for this too I know
so because you're two of the hottest
chicks I've ever seen in my life hey
what these are my daughters right her
definitely
because she's fugly just like you
who's next
he deserved that for that comment
oh my God
are you making it [ __ ] you know they
put a chemical in the pool that turns
urine blue no no no it's an old it's an
old wives tale sweetie an old wives tale
oh my God you're humiliating me
uh I'm glad that's not true
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
wow that looks so dangerous
so fun I don't like it either
good thing the kids chickened out so you
don't have to go right faded why don't
you hire somebody to do it for you
step aside Chumps
of chicken [ __ ] isn't it
that is so dangerous yeah they don't do
that anymore where the concrete is there
but
oh dear
sir
[Applause]
go down there hang about your feet is
that safe
what are you okay you're an animal why
don't you do it I got kids
yeah Wiley
no no no
as long as there's a crash on the
concrete we're okay I've seen those but
they're not as
dangerous
exist though okay Tim Duncan's had about
a hundred game winners with that bad boy
what are you watching me
impressive how come you're not out there
playing basketball you
you and the guy you got
you got scared
he's into the Chinese girl
well you're mean to him so it was great
they've streaked so much water
you can't be passed out drunk single
with no responsibility and not pay for
it I don't have to be hurt was he gonna
end up in the lake
no
Marcus the bird is all better Marcus he
wants to talk to you
food
how does he not laugh like I would have
broken so she's blonde well she's tall
super hot not your type me and Blondie
start going at it and you know we're
shaking the bed this picture behind
right on the wall Falls and goes hits
her on the floor oh my God it's just
hurt the [ __ ] two aspirins he gaps on
him like a frisbee dog
I am tired Marcus your snoring kept me
up all night long
oh no
[Music]
that is bad
what's the problem
Arrow push maybe I flirted with him but
that was just to get your attention well
what about a snoring I heard it too
[Laughter]
well what happened to your head when I
was changing into my PJs
I got the feeling that some perv was
looking through my window so I went to
go close the shade and I tripped and hit
my head
I answer your phone it was your
assistant I asked him if he canceled the
flight to Milan and he said he did
before we even came here I'm not saying
he made it up I'm thinking in his heady
he believes it's true oh no that's
messed up
we got a nanny we got so she is a nanny
no no no no she's not a nanny of course
she's a nanny when does the Line stop
stops right after this she's more of an
au pair
[Laughter]
I enjoy having a nice conversation with
a woman that wasn't going where's this
and did you pick up that
yeah well you can have nice
conversations with me
when
you come home you're just you're just
tired all the time you barely even touch
me or look at me
woman yeah you should have married
Umberto de Lucio like I oh my God oh my
God look maybe I do take you for granted
and I'm sorry
how's about I take you out every
Thursday night for date night
you know Thursday's Gray's Anatomy but
any other night would be beautiful
and with love comes hostility Rob when
he snapped at me the other day inside I
was saying do not call him a bug-eyed
sociopath with a little man complex or a
[ __ ] Filipino Fonzie
[Laughter]
in life the First Act always exciting
the second act
that's where the depth comes in Word
self-aware film
[Laughter]
I don't know man this thing was crazy
you should be all right should be no no
no
oh that looks like so much WoW
let us just hang out with our families
all right we want to relax yeah yeah
they're afraid of us yeah that's what it
is we're afraid you might eat the ball
before we even start
I think if the buzzer was here I think
he'd want us all to try
was that William Shatner
all right let's do this then it's on
everyone heard that that's right
[Music]
[Laughter]
hey look that he doesn't react just like
they're all just like oh well
foreign
[ __ ]
oh no come on man
that was intentional
uh oh I guess
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
er's real wife is that really her yeah
and I think those are his kids too
[Music]
I can't even breathe
I like since the second quarter
hey you want to pick injuries
you got it okay
you can beat up the line this time
please Sky Sports
[Music]
that's impressive
it's very Michael Jordan's number
huh
Adam Sandler
that's where Michael Jordan's number
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
oh he needs it
[Music]
[Applause]
nah kick his ass
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he gave it up he's a good man
I hate that what I hate it about cars oh
wait he helped never mind
[Music]
oh my God
[Music]
[Applause]
because in the end it isn't about
winning Greg it's about family family
gets in the way of monetary gains the
Bailey's needed to learn how to win
every once in a while and creators
needed to learn how to lose
[Music]
I would be like you embarrassed us you
embarrassed this whole family
of course he's getting along for this
hey man there's one thing they'll never
beat us yet what's this
[Music]
fired into the crowd yeah all right
everybody what are you doing there's
children
that's so messed up that is awful
oh my God
[Music]
what's that
[Music]
at least it's not poop
we win again
whoa
whoo
is there a post-credit scene
I don't think so they usually do
bloopers though don't they
uh I don't know his movies
I think this would be the type of movie
to have bloopers
Jamie Chung by the way not Maggie Jamie
that's important right
before the credits pop up I wanted oh my
God was this on my crotch the whole time
I'm sorry your webcam did you notice it
no I wasn't looking at it it is Jamie oh
God I had put my like screen down it was
like on my
ah you fell oh wow
I uh that was embarrassing okay I'm
about to be a married man Sally
I'm sorry
swimming with your crotch only fans
right now
[Music]
they got Rupert Gregson Williams to do
the music that is such a problem no
don't pause it play it hit play usually
it's I usually it's after the big
credits what damn okay nevermind there's
nothing you know like okay I know okay
Jesus oh look it's me wait go up it's
Sally lamanna off where
Sally stroganoff right there lemon's off
where are you looking oh oh that was the
character's name
ah yes yes yes yes I was in this movie
that's great I played a MILF dude my
hair's looking Wild
anyway wait I have to pretend you're
here
[Laughter]
anyway what'd you think salamander
um
I just I love Adam Sandler I love
David's fade I felt like I just got to
hang with them for a few hours you know
well the only thing missing was like a
beer I know I'm awake I found myself
kind of lost in it I felt like I was on
vacation with them
like it was very long but it was like it
was a little slow at Pirates but but it
also felt like a hangout movie like that
was the point you know what I mean it is
exactly what it is there's nothing more
than that and I was kind of prepared for
that I was told it's like Adam Sandler
just hanging out with people but I
wasn't expecting it to be
just
I won't say for for a movie without Like
a Villain it was still entertaining
because I feel like that's hard to do
yeah it was still funny it was it was
funny and um like no it wasn't like
the most hilarious movie ever but it
does feel I it is the kind of movie I
prefer watching at home where I am able
to just sit back relax
and just feel like I am on vac and
notice about like an hour in I was just
here with them on whatever random
Adventure was happening you felt like
you were just hanging out with them
because there's no real plot
right at least Friday had a real plot
it's sort of there was like conflict but
not plot if that makes sense yeah I mean
there's things that have like that
escalated and had a real like wrap
around to it in a character Journey for
Ice Cube and then here it was uh they
wanted to make sure their kids learned
there was more to life and ideas
value in Salma Hayek learning not to be
such a a tight ass about everything I
know that there was a this is there's
more to being a parent than than work
and be honest with each other and and
and uh just love each other just no need
to put up a facade just just be real I
guess there were some nice little
messages in there
okay Barney
wasn't it
sometimes you gotta learn to lose
and uh I'd be giving it generous there's
like some random [ __ ] but yeah no it's
just a fun movie about them hanging out
and um rekindling or something
I don't know I had fun watching it I
don't really expect much out of the
comedies for Adam Sandler if I'm
laughing that's all that counts I'm
having a good time that's all it counts
it is a massive cast I was gonna say
like the budget for this just to like
have the cast that's pretty much what
they spent the budget on
and then a few stunts you know here and
there but
um yeah
it was definitely like a feel-good movie
you know you're watching it and you're
like smiling the whole time so that's
not bad and uh
the only like jaw-dropping moment for me
where I was like what was like the David
Spade and daughter moment for sure oh
yeah it was hilarious I mean
um the movie the movie Just aims to make
you have a the movie just wants you to
have a good time and vacation with them
and laugh and and I feel like
isn't this like a terribly reviewed
movie
it's got it yeah I don't think people
liked it it's an Adam Sandler movie it's
the kind of movie audience is clicking I
wonder I wonder how it did box office
because I feel like this isn't the type
of movie I feel like people
would like want to paint that sounds bad
like like pay to see in theaters type
movie if that makes sense because like
it's not like a cinematic experience
type movie I don't know I've heard or do
you think they would like Adam people
show up for the Adam Sandler comedies
when they're released in theaters and
like he's gotta cut that out I love Adam
Sandler I'm not hating on you no no no
it stays in the video timing yeah I hate
Sally because I did see him in theaters
it's just this type of movie is more of
like a put on like hanging out well he
moved to Netflix
I think for a reason I mean other than a
bunch of money to do these exact kind of
films but uh it's
um I think over
I I don't know this movie did make I
mean it's Gotta Have Made money because
the you gotta see cast it got it what
yeah those are grown-ups too
where they grow up even further I have
no idea what it's about but um grown-ups
they go to avoid
162 million dollars at the domestic box
office so it made money and grown-ups
too
was also a hit it it didn't fall too shy
of of it so that means audiences
returned and wanted to experience more
of the grown-up Cinematic Universe but
uh yeah I think that I'm just the wrong
demographic for sure I mean I think you
know this is like 2010 2013 or somewhere
around that time range of when these
movies came out so I mean like now what
is this the kind of movie that would
pull in box office revenue maybe not but
at the time of Adam Sandler he couldn't
really do anything wrong back then you
know right at the time this was kind of
his Peak ish yeah and like no his
comeback right because he like had a ton
of hits kind of like in the 90s early
2000s this must have been like a
comeback movie which is probably why it
did really well because I don't remember
I don't really know the trajectory of
out of Sandler's career I feel like it's
kind of just listen I know Spanglish
come on
and then yeah well we'll see I mean he
had Jack and Jill a little bit later
then he had grown-ups too a little bit
after Jack and Jill
um but I think people just start feeling
like he was getting lazy and stuff but I
don't know to me to me his his Vibe has
always been just hanging out and
shooting the [ __ ] is has always been my
vibe with Adam Sandler and I've always
liked that about him and so I've never
been uh one to be like really offended
by his kind of like there are people who
really hate his comedy and I I've always
liked his I've always thought people who
don't have a sense of humor and take
everything too seriously I mean yeah
they're like low brow comedy jokes and
stuff but it just feels like a guy who
just laughing with [ __ ] on his own time
and then he's just like the fact that he
got so oh my God in this movie my God
yeah I love that he gets the famous
woman the hot woman to be his wife and
he's so good for him and I think his
movies also tend to have a pretty good
heart uh too like even this movie is as
a like juvenile as it is it's still got
a heart about it they always have a good
uplifting message and it's still in a
way even though the jokes are dirty the
message at the end is still kind of like
family friendly if that makes sense yeah
exactly that's what I mean it is the
heart is on display and everyone whoever
talks about Adam Sandler says how great
of a human being the guy actually is and
I feel like that shows especially with
the fact that he's always having all
these people like return to be in his
films yeah people like being with him
and working with him and I felt bad when
people were making fun of him and stuff
because I'm like as an actor like if I
got to be in an Adam Sandler movie
I would consider that Peak so what's
funny is Adam Sandler's an insanely
talented dramatic actor like that's the
no yeah uncut gems insane I mean I like
uncut gems funny people yeah Punch Drunk
Love Rain Over Me yeah he's done a lot
of like he's got a
a lot of a lot of great dramatic work
and then it's crazy to think like
watching those movies and then going
back and watching his old SNL days it's
like night and day he has so much range
it's crazy
yeah I do wish this movie if it just had
a little bit more of a of a plot of a
real plot of something of something
there of like some obstacle to overcome
because I I guess
I guess there was something there and
when they were after
um after Rob Schneider thought David's
debate slept with his daughter that yeah
all the truths were coming out and I was
like oh I guess I thought that yeah
there'd be like more to that yeah I
guess this was the plot of the movie
that that it was about like escaping
this or something like I'm expecting
something like super deep or anything
which is something to latch on to though
I was expecting a freaking bomb to be
dropped in that moment and then
everything would change and then they
would have to like try to work it out
yeah as a group but it's fun watching a
bunch of famous people get to hang out
with each other who are not doing their
top tier comedy I think the way you said
that sounded sarcastic yeah it's just
great to watch a bunch of famous people
hang out with each other his sister
watching famous people I like the famous
people no I'm jealous of them it's
genius I know it's such a lifestyle I
guess I just don't know the uh I would
like I would like uh
I wish one of them really
um if I'm gonna like judge this movie on
a some serious metric here I wish it had
someone really truly like shy you know
everyone would just felt like they were
getting their paycheck and just hanging
yeah I want I wanted someone to like
really feel like this is like great
comedy from this performer when it
really just felt like them hanging out
having a having a good time because no
one really like
shines you know they have a everyone I
think David Spade had the best moments
in terms of like making me laugh but I
just loved it
like his one-liners like got me in this
movie because some of them felt like
they were ad-libbed or something because
you could see other people laughing like
genuinely so I think they allowed that I
like Kevin James I like I like everyone
in here I thought they gave a lot of
Spotlight to Rob Schneider but he was
like the least funny one to me in this
or was it Chris Rock I'm not sure which
one was the least funny person Chris
Rock I think is hilarious
but
I think I think that's the word I'm
missing here is I feel like they could
have utilized their everyone's talents a
little bit more you know because they're
all hilarious comedians I think they're
all hilarious so yeah
Yeah the more I think about it the more
I'm like I feel like some of the
characters couldn't shine because they
were given kind of the wrong role I
think if that makes sense yeah but then
the wives were um and did you get the
hot wives I have no idea what Adam
Sandler's real wife looks like was that
her she was the one that I cut to and
then and then uh
this little girl had the line yeah
she's in like every one of those movies
I think I love how he always puts it
always makes his wives like
someone someone asked him like in an
interview like what his wife felt about
it and he said actually his wife will
like tell him on set like you need to
kiss her better like you're not doing it
right you know like she'll uh be into it
and I'm not into it but she'll she's
just touching herself no
you know what I mean
um I get what you mean
Greg let's just get rich and make money
or make movies with all our friends yeah
half-assed our talents it's just so weak
did you see the KFC like was like placed
perfectly in each shot that it was in
that it had the logo I was like yeah
that's how they paid for this movie
genius use of product placement I must
that and the Coke products too because
Dasani and Coco's like get it you know I
mean he's got the fan base I think I
think it's the thing with Adam Sandler
fans they they like to just hang out
with him they like to just check in with
him yeah I hang out with him all the
time that's kind of just how I feel is
when I watch an abstailer movie like I
just wanna I just kind of want to kick
it I don't really I don't really give a
[ __ ] for much more than that I will say
during quarantine like it got really
dark and I remember I like binged a
bunch of his movies and it made me feel
better so I appreciate him for that yeah
yeah
he's got some great ones man he's got
some great moves like Happy Madison
Happy Madison no no no but Happy Gilmore
sorry that's his belly production
company yeah yeah though I remember I
watched those and I felt happy and was
like thank you Adam Sandler I even like
such mind-numbing but good have you seen
his movie with um uh
uh Andy Samberg
um what's it called that's my boy have
you seen that one no that was on my list
though it's like a hard R comedy from
them and I think he's really funny in it
really I think they're I think it's a
really funny movie okay I'll have to
watch it then yeah I remember I think I
started watching it but I don't I don't
remember it
anyway we're done for today Sally you
can go home now okay well can I just say
he um he lived him out or he still lives
in Malibu and when I went to Malibu High
School like he would play basketball
with a bunch of local kids and stuff
like he was really cool oh okay he still
does I think and he got rejected from
IHOP have you seen that video yeah yeah
I've seen that so he's a real one we
love you Adam Sandler thanks for hanging
with us because he's watching this video
you know my episode I was watching he's
always wanted to hear what people have
to say about it he loves he loves to
hear what the opinions are about him all
the time alrighty guys well you can
follow Sally on YouTube and on Instagram
and uh when is this video dropping wait
not to cut you off it's dropping the
week I'm out of town
so your wedding week yeah no I'm out of
town another week March 3rd is when I'm
dropping
um
um why
because my announcement video will be
out by then okay well go check out
Sally's announcement video and if it's
not out this stays in the video and you
guys are gonna be like what announcement
video so the backup just it's all in
there it's all in here uncut raw
Primal like Sally she's a raw human
being when we do these zooms she keeps
the camera on her crotch repairs that
was so my heart sank like I looked I
glanced over to like bring my laptop up
I was like it's been angled at my crotch
as a whole night I would have said
something okay good okay
I would not be uh Marco
[Laughter]
you might have been dropping Clues the
whole time
no I can't see you I I rely on hearing
you and trust that the zoom is going and
we could hear each other but I mainly
just use the zoom for audio I don't I
don't need to see you I'm doing the I'm
watching them watching the movie
I'm red I'm red uh it's no worries all
right guys thank you for being here
we'll see you all soon
bye bye
[Music]